[Music]
a slight wiggle in the hips shifting
weight from one foot to another a turn
of the head as of hearing a sound subtle
gestures taking a puppet from an
inanimate object to an uncannily real
character that's the daily experience of
this man Barnaby Dixon whose Creations
have been bringing joy to Millions over
the last decade the main goal is having
people in a sense forget the mechanisms
and forget the process that has gone
into making it so they can just enjoy
the motion I think the sooner you can
get the audience to forget that you're
there the better job you're doing
[Music]
I remember a certain point of sleeping
and I was having a dream that required
me to jump instead of me jolting Myself
Away under the waking myself up with
like twitching my fingers
[Music]
Barnaby's dedication to his characters
that provide their naturalism he's a
student of anatomy and movement
animals move differently from humans but
in some kind of counter-intuitive ways
they can move in a very similar way it's
kind of interesting to look at the
anatomy like the back legs for example
of a fox in it looks like their leg is
kind of bending back because you would
imagine they have a backwards knee but
no that's their ankle sometimes by
focusing on the similarities you get a
kind of more innate sense of how
something would move so in fact only one
leg steps at any one time there's
probably a little bit of overlap but
that's generally the case if you were to
add up how long I spend thinking about
how to make puppets or what I could
Implement in puppetry design we'd be
looking at years at this point maybe
each of Barnaby's Myriad Creations has
their own unique assembly and operation
this character is called Phil and he's a
fish and he moves pretty nice in the air
but very very nice in water actually the
water has a certain resistance and it
really pushes against the fin in a
really really lovely way there is also a
mouth mechanism on this one so I can
open up the mouth like that and on the
other side of the controls it has a
little space for air so I squeeze that
down it travels down this tube here and
then out of the Public's mouth I find
it's very engaging especially in the
water
okay so here's a little run down of the
movement that we're getting so far these
are nice these are quite couldn't really
do this with other humanoid puppies that
I've made while he didn't start as a
puppeteer Barnaby's study of movement
goes back years so up until around 2014
2015 I was a stop-motion animator but
when the work takes as long as it does
with stop-motion animation you want a
technique that takes less time so that
you can simply create more content and I
kind of migrated firstly through some
kind of mix of time lapse and and stop
motion and then eventually was able to
make my models and characters move in
real time and at that point it probably
became puppetry you can see these panels
how they change color this is actually a
reflective material and I think it works
really well I've always made my own
puppets because well I didn't know how
to make conventional puppets simply
I drew so much from stop-motion
animation in terms of the movement but
also in terms of the fabrication so it's
very unlike other styles of puppetry so
this uh half of the puppet goes on my
left hand here and these two fingers
slot in like that then I have this kind
of neck piece here that goes over the
top and then the head on those two
middle fingers and that gives me the
range of motion there and this hand goes
in the bottom half of the puppet the
index finger goes in like that and the
pinky finger goes in like that and then
there's magnets in both segments so they
can just clip on like that this finger
mechanism here I can control some of the
fingers independently like the index
finger there the beak is also controlled
by the thumb the two middle fingers hold
the torso up and they also control this
mechanism in the head that gives a side
to side motion like that and my other
hand controls the bottom half of the
puppet so my index finger controls the
left leg like that and the pinky finger
controls the right leg
it's very important to get a believable
Mass if the center of mass seems in the
wrong place then it's instantly readable
[Music]
[Applause]
so there's something in puppetry called
sympathetic motion essentially anything
that moves on its own without you
controlling it so all of these dangly
elements here it's good to make use of
them that's essentially movement that
you get for free I think the sympathetic
movement adds a degree of believability
because it is responding to actual
physics now there's one here generates
the sound that is until we press this
button the sense of physics too I think
has to be handed up to some degree so it
becomes more readable to the audience so
when the puppet would jump like this for
example it's good to kind of get an
extra wobble more than it would actually
have if it was an actual living form
I think when people think about puppetry
they often think of the Muppets or
Sesame Street plenty of Puppets in the
Jim Henson world don't have feet so much
I like to get the feet in to show the
kind of full body and see what can be
done in terms of that but in truth I
think what they do is more important
these are characters that people have
fallen in love with and hopefully at a
certain point I'll get my characters to
that stage with regards to the character
development too but yeah they've been
doing it longer than me I suppose that's
my excuse Apple Juice I promise look
I'll even take a ship Reggie
among all of his characters Barnaby has
a special relationship with his first
creation so this is the object he's kind
of the mascot of my channel he has a
really really lovely head mechanism
actually very very responsive it works
with glasses hinges so there's a couple
going parallel to each other it enables
a really smooth controlled motion the
beak mechanism is very similar in
operation to brake cables and bikes
around the outside as a silicon tube so
it enables the flex but inside that
there's actually a wound spring that
I've wound myself something subtle that
I like a lot actually is the the tail
moves in a semi-sympathetic way so
there's a hinge there that will have the
tail kind of spread backwards and it
seems like he's kind of counterbalancing
himself it's a nice addition I think but
a subtle one and very easy to operate
he's missing a toe currently that's due
to the plastic degrading the little
cracking is Underside too for the same
reason plastic's breaking down a little
bit
luckily for dab chick Barnaby's
experience building his own puppets also
gives him a lot of experience fixing
them so I've had this version of dab
chick since 2018 and in that time some
of the Plastics degraded you can see
where I've fixed a little bit there but
I do want to duplicate certain elements
so that when something more important
like the face goes I'll have the option
to swap it out so what I'll be using to
duplicate the head is this mold this was
actually cast off the original dab chick
from the end of 2014 actually so this is
this is fairly ancient but what I will
do is I will use the same plastic heat
it up push it into this mold pull it out
and hopefully we'll get something that's
good to go this material although it is
very useful in lots of ways you can
reheat it if something goes wrong reheat
it and remold with it it is very hard to
work with actually it's somewhat rubbery
so you'll move it in a certain position
and there's a degree of spring back if
you make it too hot it can burn you
quite horribly too so it's not a
material that I like necessarily but it
is practical in so many other respects
that I found myself using it a lot so
the name dab chick comes from a name
that my grand dad would call his
grandkids like me included when I made
the bird puppy it just kind of popped
into my head I was like oh that's
perfect ah that looks great look at that
and a really nice color too very similar
or at least similar enough so when I
designed the puppets I limit the
materials that I use this plastic makes
up a large part of the build process
there's some miniature engineering like
silver soldering other than the plastic
some silicon and some metal elements
it's really quite limited which is quite
useful for maintenance reasons because
you can keep just a limited amount of
materials to hand dab chick may be
Barnaby's oldest and most emblematic
creation but he's always trying to push
the boundaries of what his puppets can
do
so I have this series on my channel this
puppet hosts it's kind of a ghost
storytelling series the unique feature
about this puppet is I think the screen
on the face which is actually my face
streamed in real time onto the screen so
because my mouth is part of the movement
I move my mouth in a bit more of an
exaggerated way than I would normally
move it with this puppets fabricated and
repaired as needed Barnaby can dedicate
himself to creating stories and sharing
his characters with the world I think
some days especially if I'm working on a
big project it's quite common for me to
put in 16 hours or something like that
essentially when I wake up to when I go
to sleep I'm just working on the film
the whole time I think people are
initially drawn to my work because they
haven't seen puppetry like this before
but I hope eventually the takeaways that
people almost kind of forget that
puppetry is involved at all and I think
when you get to that level of suspension
of disbelief you've done your job well
while Barnaby has created his own
methods to inspire Wonder through his
puppets he doesn't feel there's a
correct way to approach The Craft
for someone that's getting into puppetry
I would advise them almost to not look
what's out there to try and experiment
and figure out what else could be
contributed to the art form I almost
wouldn't want to prescribe any rules you
know just see what's possible because I
think that's a heck of a lot possible
that we've not explored yet
[Music]